what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I cover this week's latest
debauchery before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell the way you're
gonna be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in let's get
started so today Adam Adam Adam
look at call me a misogynist one time
I'm covering the story forever I will
cover it till I die
okay I thought me and Adam had a nice
interview I thought we were getting
along fine I see on a podcast he called
me a misogynist the woman who is
sponsoring fat chicks to lose weight
accused of hating women
the what audacity
so I found out that Adam
decided to cuck out his wife
Adam decided yes the optimal thing for
my marriage is to sell my wife's body
for money
and let another man rail her now I don't
know much about the man they picked this
guy Jason love
uh maybe he's a nice guy I don't know no
matter how nice the guy is
he is not nice enough to let him screw
your wife okay call me old-fashioned but
usually when I wanted to make money or I
don't know when I thought someone was a
cool guy
what I didn't think we would do is give
your wife to him what I didn't think we
would do is you know money even though
the crazy thing is this man is a
multi-millionaire he has one of the
biggest podcasts in LA
I used to love his interviews with like
um Kevin Samuels all these other people
he
he's a talented guy he doesn't have to
do this yet
they choose treachery
while calling me a misogynist the
audacity but you know so we covered last
week how
Adam did not like this Adam before was
like I will not let my wife screw
another man that's too far like a
reasonable man would but his wife
started talking to him getting into his
ear saying Adam why don't you you know
why don't we bring in some swinging
stuff oh I like this guy Jason here's
Jason what I don't know what they're
talking about but just long story short
so Adam is like all right
oh
as the head of the household in a
leadership position I'm gonna lead you
to this other man lead you to this other
guy so
this week he also offered he's been
making jokes about it all week you know
he told Elon Musk that you know cucking
is great he told
he he told Andrew Tate that cucking is
great he's just really promoting this
lifestyle
so now we're going to look at what his
girl had to say about her shoot with um
the other man now I'm sure she's going
to be really respectful and not not like
even if she did enjoy it maybe down play
it say it wasn't that good lie like
women women we lie about everything else
okay
why okay we lie we'll lie with a face
full of makeup we'll lie with the uh
injections full of Botox bbls we lie
about everything so I am sure she can
lie for her husband to help him save
face let's pull the clip handling it
like a champ I've been seeing he's a
toast he's lifting he's like getting
bigger did he when you get back after he
said you were like laying there dead was
there like an awkward conversation
because you had to have been like both
laying in bed and he had to have been
like okay so how was it yeah I was
trying not to talk about it at all I was
like so what do you want for dinner you
know and then he kept asking me more and
more questions and I think we got to a
point where I was just maybe a little
too honest about it and I think that's
that kind of made him feel a little
uncomfortable or jealous and that's what
I meant when I said we have to like
learn each other's boundaries all right
like why is he promoting something that
he knows deep down this is why these Sim
guys are not our friends they are not
our friends they do not look out for our
best interests and they lie I am so
tired of these men lying they are just
as bad as these modern day chicks all
right they are just as bad because they
lie to other men and tell them to do
this and they lie to women and say that
they're okay with it when they're not
and I'm sorry being a liar does not make
you a good person all right so she said
when he fell in love with her
that he couldn't see her with another
man crazy now let's let's see the next
clip things are good okay so I shot a
scene with another man for the first
time in the seven years that I've been
shooting I've always shot with my
husband and like eight days ago or
something like that I was like I'm gonna
go do my scene I came home and I feel
like it was a little rough because it
was new territory like we didn't really
know our boundaries yet
um we have had a threesome with another
guy it was just like very very early and
it wasn't even a relationship I was like
he was a [__] boy and I was the girl he
was [__] and like we had a threesome
one night and then we never talked about
it again it was like taboo to talk about
we just pretended it didn't happen but
like Adam and I have always been just
down to have some fun sexual experiences
but then as he fell like more in love
with me and I fell in love with him he
was just like I can't do that with you
and another guy I can't see with another
guy just like it wasn't gonna work for
us
why is my question like
why would you like I I want to know I
need to know the number how much are you
making off of this like I think I looked
at her of it's like 20 bucks a month
is there is it like patreon can you see
how many like Subs I don't think you can
but
I just want to know what dollar amount
would make a man consider this and this
is the thing girls will go after the
flashy guy the guy with status with
clout this is why character is the most
important thing because the question is
what will you do for money
what will you do for money so
the next clip is again it's her
respecting her husband she would never
try to make him look bad like maybe she
followed his leadership he said she
could do the cocking all right but she
certainly won't embarrass him in public
that would be crazy
in your personal opinion okay what do
you perform more uh the BBC or uh Mr uh
husband over here
is this why you put us in two different
rooms
exactly we could just be truthful here
guys truthful okay
um
I did enjoy uh Jason's new everything
new is interesting and fun but
uh what you made him leave look at that
I'm sorry I'm just trying to catch a
breath so wait did you choose Jason over
your husband
to one person for seven years and
although Adam is very exciting to me
like a new experience is always going to
be a little more interesting and
different and Adam could attest to that
like a lot of them we have are probably
a lot more fun than him just me on a
regular night right yeah yeah oh I had
fun with Jason but I still have a lot of
fun with my partner and I don't prefer
Jason's over let me let me help you
Elena Lana Elena I don't even know
her name let me help you let me help you
when they ask you that question
lie I'm sorry why okay
it's like when they ask the men they'll
ask the men is your wife the most
beautiful woman in the world you know
damn well that she is not the most
beautiful woman in the world
but the men lie to us all the time it's
like you can't just lie a little bit in
public and just say no I preferred my
husband it wasn't that great
it's like
now I know maybe some of you are
thinking Pearl
you should never lie lying is horrible
I disagree I disagree I think in this
case and in this situation you should
lie
to respect your husband it's like all
right if you're someone asks you is your
husband broke and he lost all his money
you lie it's like that one Latina chick
that was that was dating Al Capone or
whatever and they said did you see your
husband do anything illegal she's like
no
she's like no I saw nothing it's like
women will lie about her appearance will
lie about our our body count we'll lie
about we'll lie about damn near
everything but we can't lie to help our
husband's safe face
that's the crazy thing
we'll have like a pound of makeup Botox
all this [__] and yet she can't just
say you know yes my husband is the best
crazy craziness
all right so guys
I erupted Twitter
I erupted I made Twitter so mad at me I
have been tweeting up a storm
I have been tweeting laughed tweeting
right tweet tweet tweet tweet tweet and
I didn't realize the effect I could have
on people twice my age I saw Twitter
space the other day there was like two
300 people arguing about if I'm a
grifter or not
crazy I was like at 26 years old 26
years old I have these
people in a in a in a in a stance or
whatever
now
this erupted one of the reasons this
erupted that I that I pissed off the
right and the left is I I had a Tweet
now this tweet was very controversial
this was the the I this was
life-changing advice this got I think 15
million views on it
and it was just this such crazy
knowledge that I just passed on that all
of the wives were just understandable
because it was just this wisdom okay
pull pull up the the tweet
yes you're less attractive at 35 than at
25 as a woman this used to be common
sense 50 years ago
now this got 15 million views
now mind you did I say that I hate women
no
did I say that you are ugly at 35
did I say you are worthless at 35
no
did I say you're a horrible person no I
said you're less attractive now
I would think this would be like duh I
heard an Andrew Tate clip where he said
he would rather date a 19 year old than
a 26 year old
and I'm 26. now did I care
no I actually agreed with him
I actually understood where he was
coming from I'm like yeah 19 year olds
are younger hotter they've dated less
people
I if I was a guy I'd pick the 19 year
old too you know
because I don't have an ego investment
in this I don't care because if your
whole life is revolved around looks
then it whenever anyone attacks your
look or looks or your value on the
sexual Marketplace then you're going to
be upset but if your ego is not invested
in this and it's invested in other
things
um like family
Hobbies friendship whatever it is
you're really not going to be offended
by this so the funny thing is I could
see exactly where the mindset of these
women is based on how they respond to me
saying basic things now let's see the
reasonable women that they said I bet
they said thank you for telling me Pearl
I I thank you for letting me know
um this woman said I'm 50 and Fabulous
um red hair every woman
that I'm going to comment on every woman
that I'm I am going to comment on I did
not engage with them first I put out a
general statement so if you want to
whine about this you can wind somewhere
else because you guys came at me first
and now I'm just commenting and I'm
going to be adding my point of view
and if you're gonna whine about it I
suggest you maybe stop getting triggered
by basic truth that really a hundred
years ago
the older wives and mothers would say
yes it actually probably say 26. you
used to be an old maid they had terms
for this stuff old made leftover woman
like the the Town Bicycle whatever it
was if you were single over a certain
age
they would shame you for it guys this
was not crazy a hundred years ago but
this is the quality we have wives and
mothers that have such an ego investment
in their looks they cannot stand not
even being ugly but being uglier than
they were 10 years ago that is
horrible to them they cannot fathom this
so let's let's go to the next one
I would have to agree with this I'm in
the same boat I'm hotter at 39 than I
was at 25. so let's look at this so
she's got in the left it doesn't I don't
see any visible tattoos
um she I mean I guess her boobs are out
a little bit but it's certainly not as
promiscuous as the right and this is
what happens to women as they age they
get [__]
um they get more promiscuous and
honestly they get more masculine like on
the left she still looks feminine and
and pretty and on the right she looks
like a dude and she's acting like a dude
like she has her shirt off like a dude
and if women don't
have good character they get worse with
age and they're they have too much of an
ego investment in their looks because
they have nothing else to offer
um next one next one
so now I got okay now the funny thing
was I I don't know who any of these
people are I'd like to say I don't know
their backgrounds all I would see was
them engaging with me and the funny
thing was is I thought that conservative
women would not act the same way liberal
women do and this is why men have a
issue with conservative women on The
Dating Market because they act and
respond exactly like the Liberals the
only real difference is they don't
believe in abortion
um and and they vote right but really A
lot of the conservative women exact
exactly the same so we had that liberal
woman and now we have a conservative
Pearl is 26 and 38. pearl believes she's
more attractive than me because she's
younger Pearl looks like a 50 year old
man with long hair Pearl should probably
stop speaking funny thing is the funny
thing is all right all right I'm not the
queen of selfies okay all these women
they want to come at me because they've
spent like 10 years looking at
themselves finding out all these great
angles all this makeup and Botox that's
what they do in their free time now
they've mastered the art of the selfie
and they're like wow I can take a better
selfie than Pearl like honestly if your
selfie game is too good is too good I'm
like ladies how long have you been
looking at yourself in the mirror don't
you got better things to do like all
these women want to come at me because I
they're like oh you got to get better at
makeup and hair and blah blah blah but
it's like you all have this caked on
makeup now let's look at her
You Can Tell She's had work done I'm not
a work done expert I'm not a doctor but
okay we got penciled this is the
audacity these women will attack my
looks when I don't even know what you
look like
she's got penciled on eyebrows okay so
your eyebrows are fake
um let's see there's there's clearly
Contour the lips I I highly doubt those
are natural
um
maybe a nose job I don't I don't know
and I don't even care but my point is
that I didn't attack her personal
now you ladies come for me and then
whine when I talk back and I won't have
it I if you don't if you don't ever come
for me I won't attack you personally but
if you come for me I'm gonna like it's
like they want to do whatever they want
and have no response that's the crazy
thing they just want to live in la la
land and you can't ever respond so this
lady this lady it's like you have a neck
tattoo
do you really think like and you're 38
so this is the delusion of these chicks
you think even if I'm 26 and let's just
say I'm a three a guy can still have
kids with me at 38 your three years past
geriatric pregnancy
um I've even talked to fertility doctors
that don't recommend women have kids
over 40. uh because of all the
complications that come with it so it
doesn't even matter what you look like
because from a fertility point of view
you are less valuable and I I I it's not
even a competition that's the funny
thing was I wasn't even comparing myself
to them my point is that at 35 you're
less attractive than you were at 25. but
these women are so like they're so
delusional that they've never heard this
in their life you know men
um the crazy thing is men
um
even if they do a smell test like men
will pick the most like they'll take
like the shirts of women or something
the men smell them and they still pick
the younger women on Plenty of Fish
women peek at 18. men peek at 50. you
know the truth of the matter is most of
you most of you guys peaked at 18 or 19
or 20 you didn't peek at 25. sorry not
sorry I know the men aren't allowed to
say this because then they'll be called
like pedophiles or like you just like
teenagers
but all the data suggests you really
peek at like 20 maybe 22 at most
and again it's not the end of the world
there's more to life than looks but you
can tell the mentality of these chicks
based on how they respond funny thing
was people were trying to shame me for
not asking this lady to Mentor me
because I don't know who this lady is I
genuinely don't I'd like to say guys I
don't know anything about their content
maybe they have some base takes all I
know is what they're tweeting at me
left is me at 22 right as me at 32. all
these Doomer red pill females so she
calls me a Doomer red pill female saying
you're getting ugly in your 30s must be
funded by plastic surgery companies
seriously ladies stop listening to them
it's called taking care of your health
now I have no problem with women wanting
to take care of their health in their
30s and she doesn't look bad in her 30s
but this idea that she isn't uglier in
her 30s than she was in her 20s is
stupid and I quote tweet it and I bet
you
and I'm not gonna do this but I've
thought about it literally because the
men will lie but what you can do is you
can take both of these pictures put them
on like an app where men anonymously
write you and the data will tell you
they're going to pick the one on the
left
um so I I offer my opinion because she
calls me a red pill Doomer and
and she comes at me first so I'm allowed
to give my opinion you're better looking
on the left
and it was so funny because all of the
conservative females
they all started coming at me and call
it like they all start calling me names
calling me ugly saying like you're not
Trad con enough you're not trapped and
I'm just like
you you came at me and I respond and I'm
the bad do you see this it's like they
want to do whatever they want and have
zero response that's the funny thing so
the next lady
is there another one
here is me I'll be 50 next month
so you know it's like okay the liberal
ladies will come at me a little bit like
they'll show their body instead of just
their face but it's like the same
response it's like the exact same
response on the right and the left
um
yeah so now this is another I don't know
who this lady is either apparently she
works for the blaze which I honestly I
know Stephen Crowder and I think that's
his thing but I don't even know much
about the blaze like I literally
so this is a happily married wife and
mother
that said today
I need to show Pearl how hot I am I need
to prove to Pearl that I am the hottie
that I am the overly that I'm the hot
hot hottie that I am more hot than her
so they say pearl this is you in your
20s and me and your my 30s are you sure
about that
well
you know
um
lady I it's not even about you is the
crazy thing and the funny thing is it's
like you would be better looking in your
20s it's not about me versus you it's
about you would be the best looking
version of yourself in your 20s now she
just disputed this right so she she
pulls this up
the next one
she says okay and there's a picture of
her and her her 20s and her in her 30s
because she was a fatty in her 20s
hotter in your 20s you just and this is
what I said I said you were not you
would have been better looking in your
20s if you didn't waste it being fat you
are not better looking now you just
wasted your Youth and this is the
delusion we live in where these women
like she's clearly had Botox maybe a
nose job a bunch of lip filler this is
the level of the wives that we have to
look up to where the most important
thing to them is their looks like this
is a wife and mother taking time out of
her day to insult me when I never
insulted her personally like is this the
behavior of a happily married wife and
mother
like this is the crazy thing if your ego
investment is not in your looks then you
don't care
if your ego investment is in your family
and not your looks
it you're not going to be insulted by
this and it was funny I got all of these
messages from these ladies also on the
right that like they wouldn't do it
publicly because I guess there's some
girl gang of conservatives on the right
I don't really understand it
um but
I guess they have like a coalition but
they're like yeah this is delusional
this is delusional this is my point
these women are not our friends they are
not helping us okay
stay away from women that have this huge
ego investment in their looks because it
does not help us to live in delusion it
does not help us to tell us tell us yes
you're gonna be hotter in your 30s when
that's not true it's not even true that
you're going to be equally as attractive
in your 30s sorry you will not find a
single data set or study that says you
are equally as good looking in your 20s
is in your 30s You could argue that
maybe you can bring other stuff to the
table
but this idea that women are equally as
good looking and don't get uglier with
age is the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
in my life and any of you that were all
of you that were arguing with me are
delusional thank you my next story now
my next story is
um
I'm covering the fatties today guys
sorry you know it's funny I was like the
best part about not being owned by
anybody everybody calls me a grifter
when I'm self I I'm a cell phone that's
the funny thing I had 300 people arguing
if I'm a grifter and I was thinking
about how stupid this argument was I was
thinking about this because I'm thinking
all right let me get this straight
first they say my dad's funding me and
then they say I need the money
and then they say that my like that I'm
grifting for the month
look I want to talk about fatties and I
just want to cover these stories for fun
all right so let's talk about the obese
women so I was scrolling through my
timeline also on Twitter sorry guys I've
been tweeting a lot you better follow my
Twitter pearly things with a z
and I found this picture of a girl that
was a before and after
of when she met her husband to now
pull the pull the picture
all right so that was her when she met
her husband pull it up
what would you rate her one to ten
the girl he thought he'd be with forever
seven years and two kids all right this
is too much fat for two kids if you're
gonna get this fat you should at least
give him five okay like my mom
did not gain this much weight and she
gave birth to seven children
seven and you're getting this fat with
two kids really
now my question to you guys is this a
fair deal for men why do men have to
love us when we change physically and
completely look they expect us to get a
little wrinkly you're telling me the men
will accept you being a not virgin
they'll accept
you not really having any domestic
skills like they have been accepting a
lot from us
all they ask is please don't get that
please and this is what we do it's like
ladies ladies I
I don't understand like it's one thing
if he bought you at that size like if he
married you and that's how fat you were
okay that's what he signed up this is
what he signed up for on the left
and on the right this is what he got now
seriously is this a fair deal for men I
think this should you know I want to ban
divorce however I do think there may be
some exception maybe maybe if you get
over a certain weight your husband can
divorce you
I know the men can get fat the women
can't yes ladies double standards
because we are supposed to be the
beautiful ones we are supposed to be the
good looking ones that is not men's job
but yet
women the first gut reaction well what
if he gets fat what if he gets obese no
the equivalent would be what if he goes
broke and stops working and refuses to
work I don't say men just leave your
wives immediately but it's like if a
woman refuses to lose weight what is a
man supposed to do
anyway so the next the next
the next clip um so this was overweight
therapy in the 1970s
so as you've seen the body positivity
movement has been going forward it's
been doing really well all these women
have been saying I'm beautiful at any
size and I wonder what was it like in
the 70s roll the clip
overweight people tend to be dishonest
inconsistent and irresponsible
how often have we said or heard people
say I don't know why I can't lose weight
I hardly eat a thing or I was nervous
and upset I just couldn't help myself
all kinds of Alibis and excuses
our sessions together tend to debunk
these excuses and instead focus on
behavioral consistency control and
commitment with an emphasis on action
okay what are you going to try
um you've heard a lot of people talking
about today what are you going to Trump
all right well I'm gonna go on the quick
weight loss diet
and you know that's where you meet in
water that's what I'll do I'll leave I
think you've been sitting around here
and waiting for something to happen to
you that'll never happen you've got to
make it happen
yeah losing weights work I mean it's not
easy the only way you can do it just you
can't don't even get exercise I mean it
just doesn't oh I want to lose weight it
just won't come off that way Lord you
just can't lose weight by not doing
anything it's hard we had a turkey
dinner for our family on um
on Saturday and then I went out to a
movie and I just forgot that whole day
that I was on a diet I just put it right
out of my mind I know it's what we're
doing is an occupation not just it is
this is a whole way of life that we're
building for ourselves at times I felt
like well why do I have to lose weight
you know
people people look at me but it doesn't
really bother them so why should it
bother me that's I have to have a
motivation this is part of our
commitment action approach to Weight
Control
the girls meet weekly in therapy
sessions where behavioral change is
emphasized
the difference
now that's my quest my question like
what is Kinder
just let these chicks live in delusion
they're dishonest they're dishonest
people
it's so good
so true I just can't lose weight I can't
I don't even eat that much it's like the
well if you didn't eat that much you
wouldn't be fat
like I don't
and this is the thing guys look
you know I'm addicted to my sugar coffee
all right and it's a choice and I just
cannot stand living in delusion that is
my biggest pet peeve if fat people want
to be fat I wish they would do it like
not in front of me right I mean but it's
like they can live their life whatever
but
what I can't stand is pretending they're
not fat
and saying that they don't eat a lot and
acting like they can't lose weight when
it's really just a choice
so that was in the 70s let's see how
this has progressed today what is what
is it like now
the only reason people admire
bodybuilders are not obese people who
have built their body with eating huge
amounts of food is because there's
prejudice against fat people so
bodybuilding could benefit from
including the non-competitive display of
fat bodies alongside muscular ones that
paper just has an awful lot of silliness
in it and I take that one quite
personally because I don't precisely
have thin privilege myself for people
who are trying to lose weight or trying
to get healthy this kind of activism
going on in the background preventing
them getting the right advice and the
Right medical treatment is is I think
it's going to be much more of the
problem than is currently recognized
that studies is one of the smaller and
newer fields that is is really quite
worrying because it's explicitly rejects
that obesity is unhealthy and it puts
pressure on medical authorities not to
advise people to lose weight prevalent
is something that's like it sounds like
something just given to you but it's
earned and this is the thing like the
women are fatter today and they're more
delusional like one of the chicks in
that fat acceptance group like she
wasn't even big by today's standards but
back then they're like she's got a
little gut we gotta send her to Fat Camp
immediately imagine I was thinking about
this imagine if we could get like a pool
of money that paid women like a fat
Foundation that would pay women to lose
weight I genuinely think I may start
this okay because I I think a lot of
guys would donate to this group where
they literally paid us to stop being fat
I was like Solutions people
but this is the problem with the body
positivity movement
the body positivity movement is not your
friend they want you to live in delusion
they don't want to tell you the truth
and they won't be honest with you and
what they'll do is they want to be
miserable and fat so they'll make up all
these words like thin privilege and all
these words to like confuse you and not
make you understand what they're saying
and change the definition of like
healthy not healthy
tell you all your scales don't work BMI
is bad blah blah blah
and then and then act like they're
caring nice people when really all the
body positive people are evil they're
evil because they encourage obesity
which leads you to an early death
thank you last on the agenda today guys
Sean Strickland so I'm gonna be honest I
don't know anything about fighting the
UFC whatever but I saw a clip a very
based take from a man in the UFC named
Sean Strickland
and I thought this might be the most
based man I have seen in my life
I this is a great take so so bring up
bring up the footage King
Americans we need to go back to like
taking women out of the workforce maybe
that's where we [__] up you guys we
let women vote no offense think about
America prior to women voting they try
to ban alcohol I don't even drink but
I'm not trying to ban alcohol so what
you did man you let these women come in
the workforce now we make less money you
got kids raising themselves on [__]
Tick Tock we need to go back to like
1942 you know maybe 1958 after he [__]
up the Germans we need to put women back
in the kitchen we need to take [__]
only one man needs to be working so I
think as a collective Man Group we need
to elect somebody that's going to put
women back in the kitchen
but one man working weighs the wages and
build a [__] wall
have you ever thought about going to
therapy Sean for what I'm glad they said
therapy because it shows beta men and
women will weaponize therapy and mental
health to shame men for having opinions
they don't like and women they
psychoanalyze me all the time they're
let go Pearl just hates herself Pearl
just this didn't
crazy ladies so so so
I would argue back to 1920 because we
did have the Roaring 20s and around the
20s was when women got the right to vote
and a lot of times this is painted as a
good thing why wouldn't women get to
vote I mean we were just so oppressed
throughout all of history but then you
find out half of men have a job that
runs the infrastructure they pay 70 to
80 percent of the taxes
um they only seven percent of women have
infrastructure jobs they do the hardest
most dangerous jobs in society and women
there's more women so they're the
biggest single voter group so women have
more influence in politics than men
and you start to realize that you gave
women the freedom without the
responsibility and encourage
um instead it used to be that you would
get one vote for each family 85 percent
of people were married now they give two
votes so what does that do you're going
to divide the family you and your wife
are going to argue about politics and
then before you guys are like well what
kind of women are you dating this
wouldn't divide families let's talk
about covid how many crazy ladies
divorce their husbands over covid and
this is the thing they know
they know
that you can basically make women
believe anything okay you tell us some
sob story you get our heartstrings going
and they they figured this out in the
20s how easy it is to manipulate women
with propaganda and I think that's why
they gave women the right to vote was so
the powers that be could have more
influence over Society so they gave us
the right to vote they they'll show some
sob story and you you hear it all the
time oh you guys are going to be abused
by your husband how many times do you
hear that repeated on the show what are
like what do men wake up and say I want
to abuse somebody today is that what the
men are doing oh you you always have to
have a backup plan in case it doesn't
work out like there's a lot of rhetoric
that is anti-family that it goes against
the family this idea that men are
abusive you always have to have a backup
plan you have to wait to get married is
is anti all of that is anti-family and I
also think they had women start going to
colleges because if women go to college
Christians that go to college there's a
70 percent chance that they are no
longer Christian 70 so they basically
take all the Jesus out of the women and
have them go into the workforce and
basically break down the family so
and it's funny because we get all of
this power and freedom without the
responsibility of paying the taxes and
running the infrastructure of society
so you know
um I think that's a very base to take
but I saw a couple other clips from this
guy UFC dude and
um I just thought they're funny so I'm
gonna show you guys I'm doing an
interview with Nina because she has 1.3
million followers on Instagram
she intentionally makes her titties hang
out for me her boyfriend is holding a
camera while I'm trying not to look at
her they're not hanging out so when we
talk about shame here Nina let's not
let's not go too deep in the woods it's
not hanging out oh they're hanging out
this is hilarious but this is the level
of like wives the men have on the market
like she seems like a sweet chick but it
I mean they're kind of flirting in front
of her boyfriend that's the funny thing
her boyfriend's like holding the camera
while this girl's like tits are out you
know
he's funny though that guy is funny I
want to see more Clips was there any
more from him or no is that it does it
okay but let me know what you guys think
in the comments
um what was your favorite story I
covered today and what would you like to
see me cover next week or tomorrow
anyways
um also guys yeah repeal the 19th stop
telling fat chicks they're skinny
um you are uglier and I'll say uglier at
35 and then 25. you're uglier at 25 then
19 usually Adam 22
please stop letting your wife bang other
chicks I can't other men sorry I can't
watch this anymore I can't I can't deal
with this level of of craziness
um we all we have proof that you're
coping that this is a clear coat so
please just stop um let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time